and finally new rules stop saying that
whoopi goldberg getting yanked from the
view right after she attacked me on the
view is karma
there's no such thing as karma sorry
sorry but life is random the only word
to describe it when a big game hunter
gets trampled by an elephant and then
eaten by lions is hilarious
now
i mentioned this karma stuff on the show
last week because i was relating how
many texts and emails i got from people
congratulating me on receiving a
karmagram from the universe
in the form of whoopi goldberg's
chastisement so i thought this would be
a good time for a little tutorial on
karma which as americans understand it
is nothing more than an extension of the
common logical fallacy called post hoc
ergo proctor hawks
which means after that because of that
it's the fallacy that happens when
someone assumes that if one thing
follows another then the first thing
must have caused the second thing like i
wore green socks every day last year and
i never got into a car accident green
socks must prevent car accidents
[Applause]
people make this mistake all the time
but honestly washing your car doesn't
really make it rain
yeah
if it did we would have tried it here by
now
but this is how americans see karma but
karma is
not a system of reward and punishment
that's catholicism
karma is a sanskrit word meaning action
you make the conscious choice to put
good out into the world karma is the
memory of our souls the sum of a
person's actions in previous states of
existence that decide their fate in
future existences
of course that's all [ __ ] too uh i
mean
i mean
i mean reincarnation really
if that was real wouldn't we have some
evidence by now a a raccoon spelling out
in acorns help me
my name is herb zahler and i got trapped
in this raccoon body
i have a meeting next week and i can't
show up as a raccoon
so yes the buddhist version of karma is
well certainly unprovable but at least
it's a beautiful positive thought
but what americans did was take karma
and like everything else in this hateful
spiteful country turn it into something
bitter and nasty
we use it like you took the last cupcake
and god will have my revenge
ellen was mean to her staffers and then
she lost her show karma
[Laughter]
you voted for trump and now you have
covet karma now die
we took something that was meant to be
gentle kind and hopeful and turned it
into a tarantino movie
someone did you wrong and then sometime
later something bad happened to them
karma no
something bad was bound to happen to
them at some point because they're alive
if you keep living some bad things will
happen only in this dumb country do we
all make it about ourselves and connect
the two and call it karma
you stole the parking spot i was waiting
for at trader joe's enjoy your early
onset dementia
[Laughter]
no
what americans really mean when we say
karma
the foreign word that really describes
our feeling is not found in sanskrit
it's found in german shatten freud
meaning getting pleasure out of someone
else's misfortune
but your old high school boyfriend
didn't wind up a janitor because he
dumped you a week before the prom
he's a janitor because he got 600 on his
sats
and whoopi goldberg getting suspended by
the view is in karma and i wouldn't want
it if it was people have to learn to
disagree in this country and not hate
for it
whoopi said i was flippant and immoral
for saying it's time to chuck the masks
and get back to normal well
our 43 states here in america
and the entire nations of england
denmark sweden and finland flippant
because they're saying the same thing
now
covet is so much more complicated than
just i'm for more safety than you are
and therefore i'm a better person
but whoopi is misinformed on many
aspects of the covet debate
after she got it recently she said that
being vaccinated
quote doesn't stop omicron and that's
the problem of the variant because it
gets stronger
actually it usually gets weaker
as is the case with this one but that's
okay
she's allowed to be wrong [ __ ] it's 11
a.m
who who can think clearly at that hour
i'm still in rem sleep
and as i mentioned last week how could a
nation like america have maintained an
apartheid state for the vast majority of
its history and expect the views of the
races to match on all matters it's
amazing they match on any whoopi
goldberg shouldn't have to conform to or
apologize for her views on race as much
as i disagree with them and she
certainly shouldn't have to sit out like
a child and think about what she did
the view suspending someone for sharing
a view is like firing pat sajak for
selling a vowel
we have got to get past this endless
unforgiving zero tolerance mindset bent
on punishing and disappearing anyone
caught saying the wrong thing
the right response to speech you don't
like is more speech
not the lazy cowardly response of
canceling people
[Applause]
this is a big country with lots of
people who don't think like you we all
only need to agree on free speech itself
that's my religious belief that's the
timeless principle i live by i don't
like what whoopi said about race she
didn't like what i said about covid so
what
the real essence of karma by the way is
non-attachment letting [ __ ] go it's very
zen
oh and by the way
no one knows what that means either
you